pierre pin situé à 15 kilomètres de kiev
les habitants qui est une ville pilonnée
sans relâche par l'armée russe
j'ai oublié la dernière fois que j'ai
mangé j'ai tellement peur je continue ma
sundin nous avons passé de bons jours
sous les bombardements les tanks ont
roulé sur notre jardin trois mille
personnes ont pu être extraits dir pinet
de vol au me reste de la capitale malgré
une cinquantaine de cas d'évacuation
bloqués dans la région selon les
autorités locales la russie et l'ukraine
se sont entendues sur des cessez-le-feu
locaux afin d'établir des couloirs
humanitaires
autour de zones durement frappées par
les combats des derniers jours a nro
darsouni et is you des milliers de
civils ont également pu être évacués
mercredi nous avons réussi à organiser
trois couloirs humanitaires depuis
soumis depuis des villes de la région de
kent et depuis nro d'art au total 35
mille personnes ont été
tuées dans le sud est à marioupol les
troupes russes assiègent la ville
portuaire trois cent mille civils
restent coincés des tentative
d'évacuation ont échoué à plusieurs
reprises les deux camps s'en rejetant
mutuellement la responsabilité